wir sind bei popstars und wir haben
schon 50 von lavive ihr sarah hatten wir
schon mal und michael ist die neue im
bunde ja wie ist die lager ich frage mal
dich zuerst auf jeden fall total super
also ich bin glücklich dass ich bei
lavive dabei sein kann und mit sarah
zusammen
es kann bloß gut werden also vor allem
letzten interview hatte er gesagt ja am
liebsten würde ich mir wünschen dass
sonja dabei ist das hat jetzt noch nicht
so ganz klappt ist sauer
ja denn ich michael gesagt ich bin
eigentlich nicht sauer jeder von uns hat
seinen favoriten den er gerne in der
band haben möchte ist es einfach logisch
also ich habe auch meine leute die ich
gerne in der band haben wollen ok nahmen
die bauern katrin hätte ich am liebsten
noch mit in der bändern wäre es
eigentlich so richtig schön auch vom
optischen herren die stimmen der perfekt
ja und was sagst du dazu der wm nicht
dabei wäre nicht dabei
aber wenn wir jetzt wenn ihr unser aus
irgendeinem grund nicht reinkommt dann
wäre ich auch dafür
für die beiden katrin und die bar top
also ihr favorisiert kathy beys müsstet
ihr ja die leute da draußen davon
überzeugen dass ihr eure band so
zusammenbekommt wir sehen möchte was
sind dann die argumente also das erste
argument zu katrin ist koste super
arbeit zurück
das zweite argument ist vielleicht ein
bisschen oberflächlich aber man muss das
ja auch bedenken sie ist blond okay für
das bild dann ist sie sehr sehr nett
höflich freundlich ein bisschen zickig
was auch mal ganz gut ist wenn man seine
meinung gut vertreten kann und sie weiß
einfach genau was es bedeutet hier zu
sein und bei diva da brauche ich gar
nicht sagen wie bringt einfach alles mit
meiner meinung nach
und dazu ist noch sehr sehr höflich sehr
sehr nett also ich muss sagen wir kommen
auch alle gut mit dem zurecht ich glaube
es gab noch nie irgendwie ja die war
kathrin irgendwen davon der sich
irgendwie mal quer gestellt hat zwar
immer super was sagt er jetzt den
restlichen kandidaten ja was was soll
man dazu sagen ich meine gut es reise
ein bisschen im stürmisch und weiß
manchmal nicht so ganz
wie sie es eigentlich richtig anstellen
sollte julia ist meiner meinung nach
einfach noch zu jung für eine band passt
wirklich eher als frontfrau zu einer
rockband dazu bewegen ihre stimme auch
und den haben wir noch dass khalil
pascal ihn glaubt berlin ist glaube ich
auch mehr einzelkünstlern sie ist eine
super sängerin gar kein frage ich
schlimmes super meiner meinung nach auch
allerdings ist sie glaube ich um in
einer gruppe zu sein
das heißt da wird es lavive nicht lange
geben doch natürlich egal wer reinkommt
lavive ist oder so geben wir werden uns
natürlich alle egal in welcher
konstellation es letztendlich ist
verstehen und letztendlich dafür
arbeiten das ist genau so ist wie wir
uns alle vorstellen nämlich dass die
bands erfolgreich wird und da lassen wir
dann auch mal alle sachen außen vor ob
ich jetzt ihre schuhe da nicht mag oder
nicht ist egal es endlich mal wenn ich
irgendwo eine neue arbeitsstelle komme
kann ich auch nicht suchen wenn ich als
vorgesetzten haben will oder als
mitarbeiter gut aber schon viele girl
band sind auseinandergeflogen also
irgendwie viel kraft ist ja doch da wenn
ja aber es kann ja auch mal sein
manchmal es ist ja auch so dass man
setzten sich am anfang versteht und es
hinterher kraft also man kann es nicht
voraussehen
von daher ist kann auch sein dass wir
sagen hey julia und pascal ihr geht
jetzt gar nicht würde aber vielleicht
hinter klappen aber wenn wir jetzt
gerade noch die möglichkeit haben zu
sagen wir gerne hätten
dann müssen auch erst mal so machen wie
seht ihr denn jetzt so in die zukunft
für dich hat sich ja jetzt eben erst vor
kurzem als quasi eine ganz konkrete neue
perspektive ergeben was ist das
aufregung erwartungs fieber oder was
fühlst du es ist auf jeden fall alles
gemischt das ist auch ein bisschen angst
dabei vor dem was kommt und wird die
band bestehen und können wir in die
fußstapfen von monrose treten also es
ist ja quasi platz für frei gemacht
jetzt ja aber wie gesagt wir müssen
einfach versuchen dieses niveau von
popstars von den popstars band monrose
einfach zu erhalten und ich glaube das
ist unser
das ziel auch mindestens so lange also
zu bestehen wie monrose es gemacht hat
und uns auch dann im guten zu trennen
falls es überhaupt dazu kommen sollte
was wir natürlich nicht hoffen wir
hoffen dass die band sehr lange bestehen
wird und dass wir da unseren spaß dabei
haben es ist natürlich jetzt für mich
auch das gefühl einfach ich habe ein
riesengroßes bauchkribbeln das ist
einfach gut wird schon allein weiß sarah
und ich jetzt in der band sind und ja es
kann bloß gut werden also ich hab da
schon ich bin sehr positiv darauf
bestimmte optimistische ok bereitet ihr
denn jetzt schon irgendetwas vor oder
fängt das quasi mit ende der letzten
live show an
na ja also wir haben natürlich schon
unsere pläne im kopf was es stehen auch
schon viele termine an wenn die band
dann besteht also wir haben auf jeden
fall kräftig zu tun und zu trainieren
also das wird der hammer so man wird
sehr viel von uns ferne zukunft den song
denn jetzt singen wie der allererste
single seite mit ihnen zufrieden
also ich finde ihn schon sehr super den
song also ich glaube wird viele leute da
draußen ansprechen also er ist sehr
tanzbar und er macht einfach so eine
positive laune auch und ich glaube da
wird sehr oft in discos gespielt werden
und hat da wo die jungen leute einfach
hingehen und gute musik hören wollen
also ich glaube schon dass er
hoffentlich auch in den charts landen
wird und dass es den leuten da draußen
auch so gefällt wie uns gefällt dir auch
sich genauso was ich war von anfang an
begeistert vom song ich denke dass es
gerade auch sehr viele mädels im alter
zwischen elf bis 16 ansprechen wird
darüber hinaus auch aber gerade so
speziell die sehr sehr sehr tanzbare
nummer wie michael schon sagte und auf
jeden fall mit viel spaß verbunden aber
ich stelle mir das dann vor werden unser
unsere single an jetzt verkauft wird und
mädels sich so treffend zum abends zum
disco zum schminken alle zusammen dass
sie da diese zogen danach auf der party
gehen ok dann würde ich mal sagen
schreibt eure meinung dazu unter dieses
video in die kommentare die beiden
werden es lesen und kriegen dann schon
mal so einen kleinen trend mit wie es
laufen könnte
ihr könnt ihr dann rein schreiben wie er
das findet was da gesagt worden ist wenn
er dazu kommen ich glaube euch gefällt
ich hoffe ist euch gefällt aber wenn es
euch nicht gefällt dann seid ehrlich und
schreibt uns vielleicht können wir davon
auch ein paar sachen mitnehmen
genau wie das vielleicht noch beim ampel
formen und gerne erhöhen oder so genau
die sind für alle kritiken ob gut oder
schlecht offen
anregungen kritik
verbesserungsvorschläge in die
kommentare
stimmt genau